The company or country is in
decline. You can try voice
or you can try exit.
Voice is basically changing the
system from within, whereas
exit is leaving to create the new
system.
In 2013, the serial entrepreneur
Balaji Srinivasan gave a widely
discussed talk at the tech incubator
Y Combinator on a paradigm
derived from the work of the
economist Albert O.
Hirschman.
There are two paths to reform, he
explained.
To speak up and remake a system from
within.
Or to leave and build something new
that might one day take its place.
That latter concept of exit
is the framework through which
Silicon Valley solves problems,
and it captures the worldview of
Srinivasan, who venture capitalist
Marc Andreessen has said has the
highest output per minute of new
ideas of anybody I've ever
met in my life.
In his new book, The Network State
How to Start a New Country,
Srinivasan makes the case for
exiting today's nation states as
they exist and migrating much,
though not all of our lives onto
the Internet.
Ever improving digital tools give
humans an unprecedented and
always accelerating ability to
create opt in, fully
voluntary communities where people
choose to meet, work,
live and love from existing
countries that are changing
themselves by attracting immigrants
with the promise of a better
standard of living.
To blockchain communities that draw
participants by laying out clear cut
contractual rules, responsibilities
and obligations, Srinivasan
articulates a future
that is profoundly democratic and
consensual, thus liberating
us from a status quo in which
self-determination is usually
little more than a pipe dream.
Srinivasan holds a Ph.D.
in electrical engineering from
Stanford.
He co-founded the genetic testing
firm Counsyl, and he served as
the first chief technology officer
of Coinbase, the popular
cryptocurrency exchange.
He's been a fierce critic over the
years of the FDA, which might
account for his being shortlisted to
head up the agency under Donald
Trump.
What if this coronavirus is the
pandemic that public health people
have been warning about for years?
He tweeted in January 2020,
as Vox and mainstream outlets
were busy attacking Silicon Valley
venture capitalists for taking
the crisis too seriously.
It would accelerate many preexisting
trends, he wrote: border closures,
nationalism, social isolation,
preppers, remote work, face
masks, distrust in governments.
Reason talked with Srinivasan about
the network state, the rise
of China as a tightly centralized
global power, why Peter Thiel
is part of the descending class,
and the future of freedom, both
online and off.
Balaji. Thanks for talking to
Reason.
Good to be here.
The book the new book is or
the book is The Networked State.
Give me the elevator pitch
or given the kind
of utopian dimension and
reach of this, what's the space
elevator pitch?
Sure, space elevator pitch. Well, I
actually have something.
You know, if you go to
thenetworkstate.com, you know,
the full book is online.
And I actually have a one sentence,
one image.
1000 word.
1000 word version.
Yes.
Yeah, that's right.
So the one sentence version
is a network state
is a highly aligned
online community capable of
collective action that
crowdfunds territory and eventually
obtains diplomatic recognition.
And, you know, just to take
that definition, right.
Highly aligned online community,
that is not
a Signal group, a WhatsApp group
or a Facebook group.
You know, a Twitter following, even
even a discord is really not a
highly aligned online community.
Why? Because if you
if you have a million followers and
you tweet, a thousand likes might be
a lot, and that's point 1%
conversion.
Whereas if you're a CEO and you call
an all hands and you have 100
employees, you'll have under 100
people attend, you'll be double
digits at least. Right?
So that's not a 1% conversion
rate. That's closer to 100%,
certainly way more than 10%.
Right. And so highly aligned
community is actually one that
it has is capable of doing things
here that's capable of collective
action. It's also highly aligned in
another sense, which is it
shares common values.
The people on Facebook don't think
of themselves as Facebookers or
Twitter don't think of themselves as
twittarions, whereas there are
people who hold Bitcoin think
themselves think of themselves as
bitcoiners, okay?
Right.
Or think of themselves at the top of
their identity stack is this right?
So highly aligned means that the
online community that they belong to
is at the top of their identity
stack. They identify as that first,
perhaps above the city or the
country that they live in.
Okay. Right. So highly like online
community capable of collective
action. As you mentioned, they can
all do things together.
And the very basic
is if you put out a notification
to a group of thousand,
all 1000 people should like a tweet.
That's like a baseline.
That's a simple thing, that's one
bit.
But once you start.
Bitcoin, is Bitcoin
a fully realized network state for
you?
No. It's not and it won't be.
And the reason it's just not,
there's lots of things that are
that have aspects of a network state
that are not what I'm calling a
network state. And the reason is,
you know, a currency is a part of
the country, but it is not a country
in its own right, you know.
There's aspects of Facebook,
facebook certainly has large sums of
people, it shows you can shape
country scale on the Internet.
But it was not.
People did not join Facebook
with the concept that Zuck
is their president.
Right. Right. Did not sign a social
smart contract going.
It has become a quasi government in
some ways.
But that's like this uneasy hybrid
transitional phase, as opposed
to something where you go in eyes
open and you literally sign
digitally sign a social smart
contract. We can make that more than
a metaphor. You know, we take the
resilient concept of the social
contract and the crypto concept,
smart contract. We put those
together.
So just to come back
to your thing the definition highly
aligned online community.
So it's really got shared beliefs,
top of the identity stack, capable
of collective action.
So you can do a thousand lives.
That crowdfund's territory.
So that's a much higher bar for
collective action. That's not simply
a thousand people liking something.
That's a thousand people who pool
their funds and crowdfund territory,
not necessarily in one place.
There can be ten people who get a
group house and 100 people who buy
a cul de sac and, you know, 50
people who buy a ranch in different
parts of the world and in their
network together and they think of
themselves as part of the same
community in the same way that
somebody living in Hawaii
or Guam or Alaska
thinks of themselves as part of the
United States, despite living
far away from the continental United
States. In the same way the people
who live on the islands of
Indonesia, they're separated by
ocean.
Well, what if you have islands that
are separated by internet but still
think of themselves as part of the
same country psychologically?
Fundamentally, it is about the
software, it's all in people's heads.